[Music]
the matrix is one of those movies that
has imprinted itself on a whole
generation I remember very vividly
seeing it for the first time and it had
a powerful effect on me the language of
the matrix has come to undergird much of
our political discourse and strangely on
both sides of the political aisle and
though I have to admit it would be
impossible to go through all of the
symbolism in the movie hopefully I can
follow a thread that will make its basic
structure available The Matrix is full
of small symbolic references and so many
people have written discussed and
explored all of these references the
names the play on words but but dwelling
too much on these like the name Trinity
or Morpheus or the play between neo and
the one I think can become a distraction
and it's also obvious that the Wachowski
z-- through in a large number of
references which are not completely
coherent and can confuse us as we
attempt to make out the basic structure
of the story which is really a battle
between two clear sides at least in the
first movie the two sides can be
described in many ways it's a battle
between the mind and the body artificial
intelligence and man we can say the the
artificial and the natural in general
it's a battle between control and
freedom determinism and free will purity
and mixture conformity and difference
conservativism and change it's also
reason versus faith but also reason
versus intuition reason versus love
reason versus desire and ultimately it
pits the system no matter how you see it
against the individual once one sees the
basic opposition we can follow the
thread the opening of the movie is the
key Trinity a hacker who's attempting to
find neo so to set him free
from this system is confronted with
police and agents of the matrix and in
that scene we see both the set up of
hierarchy which is shown as the agents
pulling rank on the policemen and we
also see the self willing of Trinity
lying on her back telling herself to get
up so to get out of the matrix before
she's killed by the authority structure
the fact that both Trinity and the
agents know that the rules which
regulate the matrix are artificial
constructs gives them special powers in
manipulating how they interact with it
the conflict between the two sides plays
itself out at several levels first off
this happens within Neos life he has two
identities this is particularly made
clear by agent Smith when the agents
capture him in the beginning on one hand
we are told he is Thomas Anderson a cog
in his system an employee for a software
company who contributes to the social
fabric pays his taxes etc on the other
hand he's a hacker who's chosen his own
name neo and in that identity he must
hide from this system works to subvert
infiltrate and undermine the system of
order working to solve the conspiracy of
which he has an intuition and which is
the key to his own sense of being out of
place out of sync with reality as a
Thomas he doubts
this can't be what be real it's
important to understand how adherence to
conspiracy theory is far more a meta
question than one might think beyond the
specifics of this or that conspiracy
it's the sign of an extreme duality the
lack of unity between the opposites of
control and freedom system and
individual conspiracy theory is first
and foremost doubt about the system of
order itself an intuition that it has
become corrupt and exists only to serve
its own nefarious ends which are being
hidden by the very Authority and power
embodied by the system itself the system
like the the totalitarian governments of
the 20th century
like in Orwell's 1984 is only there to
self perpetuate its capacity to control
and in doing so reduces the human being
to a tool so in this vision social order
is seen as crushing the logos of man the
will and freedom which makes them in the
image of God we could say this is of
course represented quite forcefully in
the moment where neo loses his mouth
during the interrogation scene now in
the matrix the system of control is
invisible it's in fact the very shape of
phenomenological reality as it presents
itself to the person the system of
control only becomes visible and violent
when you question it this can have some
frightening consequences for the message
of the film the system of control is
represented as our very frame of
perception which is programmed and
controlled without us knowing it when
Morpheus is explaining to neo what the
matrix is he gives several human
activities as examples of places where
you are engaging with the matrix first
he speaks of the matrix as that frame
for reality watching television
looking through your window but then he
says you can feel it when you go to work
when you go to church when you pay your
taxes
these examples are specifically
structured according to the social
organization which could be found let's
say in the Middle Ages and and which is
similar to other structure than many
cultures the three orders which
correspond to the working slash business
class the ruling class and the priestly
spiritual caste the point is that behind
the science-fiction facade the matrix is
not so much about robots putting humans
in vats but is simply order itself view
negatively as a system of control
Morpheus gives us a final definition
what is the matrix control a
computer-generated dream world built to
keep us under control in order to change
us to change human beings into a battery
the radicality of how encompassing the
matrix is makes any act against it
justifiable terrorism of course but also
any individual who stands to defend the
system is an agent of the system even
though they might not even know what
they're doing or know about the matrix
if you are not one of us you are one of
them and those those agents are those
people in the matrix can be eliminated
as needed without moral consequence this
type of discourse is truly that of the
revolutionary the recent resurgence of
notions like systemic oppression or
group guilt that is the fact that you're
guilty of all the crimes of a group
simply for being a member of that group
is an example of the type of thinking
which animates the Matrix movie that
means that anyone we haven't unplugged
is potentially an agent in a normal
vision of the world a relationship with
the system of order is seen as exchange
people do act as batteries for
organizations whether it be the state
the church but it's also true of your
local sports club or
you're on sniffing group individual
participation acts as fuel by which the
higher-order identity and an order
itself can continue to exist but in a
normal vision that system of order also
offers identity structure purpose and
cohesion to the group which feeds it
while also leaving room for the let's
say idiosyncrasies and our private world
on the side of the human resistance we
see lined up a series of qualities which
bolster the basic opposition this basic
opposition against the system so if the
matrix is conformity when the
Nebuchadnezzar crew enters the matrix
they're shown as idiosyncratic in their
appearance if the matrix is filled with
white people in fact the agents are all
white men the resistance appears as
multicultural and diverse we find a form
of spirituality in the resistance but
this faith is seen as individual faith
as short-circuiting reason and
predictability and each person's belief
you know does not have to coincide with
what others believe in order for those
beliefs to have value what was said was
for you and for you alone and in the end
the ultimate faith is the faith in
oneself for it is finally by believing
that he is the one that neo is able to
explode the structure of control this
understanding of our position to the
system also shows us the meaning of the
Oracle who demonstrates that there are
limits to coherent linear thinking and
and human causality is not always linear
and don't worry about today
would raise that face I'm sorry
I said don't worry about it but often
runs backwards and forwards in all
directions intuition often Trump's
reason and there is great power to be
found in that space or even freedom and
determinism break down and when Morpheus
presents neo with the two pills it is
choosing between these two sides the
question of deciding which is more real
the blue side of the simple the
straightforward and decide where your
experience of the world matches your
theory of the world or else the
complicated unbelievable vision or
absolutely nothing is what it seems
first off it's important to say that we
make this decision every time someone
makes a statement to us do we trust or
distrust is this truth or a lie is the
pronouncement there to show us or to
mask from us reality in this image of
the pills that Wachowski use a very deep
intuitive structure which goes beyond
the confines of the movie of course it
is what many have called the right and
the left hand water and fire the blue
side of mercy and the red side of rigor
the side of reason and the side of the
passions the straight and the crooked
one could say that it is the two sides
of the brain but it is the reflection of
a greater pattern which is that we
vacillate between coherence and
completeness are things simple moving
towards unity or are they complicated
moving towards flux what is important to
understand is at least in the first
movie the opposites are portrayed within
a liberation frame of modern politics
the narrative is one of revolution we
can't avoid that and the breaking of
systems of order and and in this case
the structures the frames are seen as
impeding the real which is identified
mostly with the body with instinct the
individual and the possibility of cell
determination of being whatever you want
to be no matter what the social fabric
seems to impose in many instances neo
says that he will not accept to be
subject to the rules that he is in
control of his own fate do you believe
in fate you know why not because I don't
like the idea that I'm not in control of
my life several people have seen the
resemblance between the matrix and
platonism in relation to the allegory of
the cave and this is an obvious
comparison but the matrix presents us
with the form of reverse Platonism we
could say or what is most real is not
the reality of stable forms which are
beyond even the mental reign realm but
it is a fight between the controlling
mind and the flux of the body by
understanding how rules structures and
frames of reference you know as mental
tyrannies are artificial and malleable
one acquires special powers in shaping
and twisting reality for revolutionary
ends in the sense the matrix and how it
works is very akin to magic which
attempts to master the structures of
conscience and manifestation in order to
manipulate them and so we follow the
story of neo as we do that we do have a
descent into the underworld of sorts neo
leaves the comfort of the matrix and is
dumped into the real world and this
takes on the imagery of baptism as neo
is reborn into the real world outside
the matrix as he does that he's then
he's in a sense to learn to control the
very thing that imprisoned him he
accepts to risk his life to go into the
matrix to save his new father figure
Morpheus and in doing so becomes the one
the individual which can stand against
the system and explode it from within in
the sense neo follows the Joseph
Campbell hero's path though there is
quite a bit of confusion and the
confusion
is due to the basic inversion of the
Neoplatonic vision on the one hand the
matrix is viewed as the world of shadow
like the underworld but the matrix is
ordered and regular and reality is
represented as a devastated world of
death welcome to the desert of the real
the matrix is presented as the dream
world but leaving the matrix is done
with Alice and wonderland imagery such
as entering the looking-glass and
tumbling down the rabbit hole which in
which in Lewis Carroll are seen as
equivalent to the dream world there's
even a scene where as neo is about to
exit the matrix he's told by cypher
buckle your seat belt Dorothy because
Kansas is going bye-bye which is strange
because in The Wizard of Oz movie
Dorothy's trip is seen as a dream to me
the ultimate example is in the reference
to the Nebuchadnezzar in the movie in
the Biblical Book of Daniel
Nebuchadnezzar is the king who dreams of
an order that is toppled a giant statue
which is knocked down by an uncut stone
a tree that is also cut down so we can
understand why Morpheus ha's ship is
named that but in the biblical story
Nebuchadnezzar takes the red pill we
could say you know he descends into the
body he exits the control of the city
and lives like a beast in the field this
descent is seen as punishment for hubris
this forgetting of order this more
primordial animal existence is actually
far more akin to a dream the life
outside the city and civilization is
exactly a world where borders are gone
and where anything is possible and this
is exactly what Neil calls for at the
very end of the movie such a such a
reality is equivalent to the dream where
a structures of order no longer function
and the matrix the systems of order and
coherence would be equivalent to the
waking world but of course if you follow
this line far enough you'll see that it
will also lead you into contradiction it
seems in fact that many of the tropes in
the matrix collapse under their own
internal contradiction
also people have attempted to make
references to Christianity and I can
understand why neo obviously is made to
be an image of Christ this is mentioned
explicitly in the movie he's the savior
and there are you know other interesting
parallels to make even dies and
resurrects before fully attaining his
highest form yet one must be cautious of
it because the structure of the movie is
truly a revolutionary one so if it is
Christian it is in line with liberation
theology and things of the sort we see
this as neo resurrects and becomes the
one he's in the matrix but he also
stands outside it he can fully see the
matrix as the construct that it is and
in that place the only word he utters is
no and this no is the shape of the movie
for the highest form of the individual
is seen as he or she who resists the
control the oppressive system of order
Christ has come to reunite heaven and
earth show us a place where all things
can come together and so although Christ
did common part as the uncut stone which
topples the statue in Nebuchadnezzar's
dream this is this is a traditional
interpretation he did not oppose Rome in
a revolutionary sense by accepting to
die he transformed Rome from within
until the corrupt system of order Rome
itself which had conspired in his murder
and then persecuted his disciple for
centuries was finally conquered from
within and transformed not exploded as
for the matrix the very last scene in
the movie clinches the whole story
Nero declares the system is afraid of
change we see the words system failure
as neo says he does not know the future
causality of his actions does not know
what effects they will have his side is
one for now I'm going to show them a
world
without you a world without rules and
controls Without Borders or boundaries a
world where anything is possible that is
of course the final message which is
that the truly real is a world without
order without system and without limits
where there is no relationship between
the categories of the world and in our
own possible engagement with it that is
what Larry and Andy Wachowski sorry no
way Larry and lana wachowski is that
right no no no no no wait lily and lana
wachowski that's what they're aiming for
the final statement was already framed
in sexual imagery as a promise of the
freedom we're talking about right at the
very outset of the movie the first time
Neel encounters Trinity at some SNM rave
and now at the very end Neil's
declaration is cast in political
discourse as Rage Against the Machine
comes on wailing it's criticism of the
American government and the abuses
murders and systems of control it tried
to instigate and preserve during the
20th century all of this is of course
only one side of the equation for it is
true that the systems of order can be
corrupt her annika land controlling it
is true that sometimes the individual
must stand and oppose this corruption we
see this in the biblical prophets
culminating in st. John the Baptist but
it is also true that there cannot be a
world without limits without borders
such a world would not be a world but
would be chaos itself the balance is
difficult but without it we find
ourselves in the strange place we stand
today whereas the revolutionary
narrative exemplified in the matrix has
now taken over institutions in our
universities and governments through
social justice initiatives you know we
we find that it is more
are conservative types who are used
using matrix analogies like the red pill
or tumbling down the rabbit hole it is
the more conservative types that are
questioning the narrative that is
presented to us by the system of control
so maybe all I can tell you is wake up
the matrix has you if you enjoyed this
content and our exploration of symbolism
get involved I love to read your
insights and questions in the comment
section you can also share this video on
social media to your friends and as you
can please consider supporting us
financially through patreon or PayPal
you'll find those links in the
description below